hello guys I'm Gregory Elbe and I am
John little while ago before I left for
Switzerland
I posted a reaction to a Russian film
called Guardians and I thought it looked
cool
most of the comments came in saying that
it's from a director that people in
Russia hate Phil well there's a reason
they sent that trailer here though cuz
ya cuz you're gonna see him you don't
know the conduct you cool a lot of
people a lot of Russian followers of the
channel and the first person I saw that
requested it I want to give him a
shout-out flate teks one flat teks once
it's you're the first one I'm gonna
shout you out who's that we should check
out the trailer for Viking that one
looks really good and then a lot of
people were comedy yeah if you're
anything you should watch the trailer
for Viking so okay I'm interested in
more foreign cinema what if they're
[ __ ] with us and they hate this
director even bit less they want us to
hate this a wonder is enjoy our
reputation in Russian
Wow beautiful shot there whoa yeah
latina yes anybody want
this is no fun with ya
poor horses
Saiki
how they say in december 2016 in the
truth one thing I like about when I
watch foreign trailers is scene style
and tone that's what I mainly took away
from this was looking at the style and
imagery of this film especially for a
trailer of its type it's easy for me to
imagine American filmmakers casting
British people to be these guys yeah my
teams and maybe capitalizing more on the
romantic aspect of it yeah Hollywood has
a fire yeah yeah and but seeing this
vibe it does seem to be more about this
man wanting to take like the the man who
was exiled and wanting to restore peace
and take back the throne I like the
aspect of his character there of how he
was a man from exile and they're calling
him like he's a slave he's a peasant he
shouldn't be someone who's leading an
army and all these things like he should
be taken down to you or status yeah I
have their show but it's really showing
that he has the skill and the mentality
that he takes and I love that mower he's
like oh I want to marry her a lot of
foreign trailers I see and especially
this one is like they feel like a lot of
real people made them I don't know how
else to kind of put that sentence
together if this was a Hollywood movie I
feel like it would kind of feel like a
fantasy where those battle sequences
just look grungy and yeah nasty and and
like they really got a lot of people
together and simulated a battle and
that's you know what looks so incredible
to me is that sort of old-school we got
a whole bunch of people to be in this
scene sort of vibe where everything's
really there yeah it's like they clearly
shot on real locations
it looks like the sets were beautifully
built looks like they had tons of
actually they're really shot in the snow
like they're a couple CG you know
sequences in this trailer but you know
it's not like Ben Hur in the States
that's what I think what I'm shiny and a
lot of CGI and like this feels like
because this could have a hard or I
don't know a rating it is but I feel
like it's gonna be rated R yeah there
seems to be like others and really
wasn't there seems to be like a gritty
nastiness to this look with a lot of
real stuntmen involved in it
and a great production design if
anything and of all films ever released
in the States it reminds me of the
original Lord of the Rings yeah not The
Hobbit but the Lord of the Ring well
yeah that's a good contrast to draw
because the Hobbit kind of does fall
into every sort of big shiny studio
pitfall that Lord of the Rings avoids
like this does feel like a real epic the
battle sequence is like [ __ ] intense
like like that one moment where they
like take this spike and they shove that
guy into the wallet yeah like the
violence and it does look appealing
it's called Viking and whenever I think
of Vikings I think of violence that's
usually one of the first things that
comes to mind for me is brutal violence
or like when Nicholas Winton roughened
did Valhalla Rising or you know things
like that where it has a real nastiness
to it a real like subdued down to the
earth travelers and he's not as
saturated yeah it feels like like at
least it'll encapsulate a lot of the
roughness of this world as well like
it's not glamorous yeah a period piece
you know as much I'm sure that with a
film this scale there's always some kind
of glamour flourishes but movies like
these always look a lot less glamorous
to me than ours do then a lot of our
there willing to take a little bit more
risk in terms of stuff like that
yeah and just throw it down it's like
this looks like you know you think of
Game of Thrones while you're watching
this sort of just like you know there's
some really grimy like holy [ __ ] stuff
in this trailer that really looks
impressive I don't know who the main
actor is I've never heard of anyone
involved in this film before but the
main actor the guy who's like leading
the charge finding myself getting pumped
up like Cohen rooting for this guy he's
got the underdog story of this play with
me yeah yes and you know that story of
like honoring tradition honoring your
bloodline I love it a lot of this looks
really [ __ ] cool looks more along the
lines of like the director's cut a King
Arthur and yeah like that you know I
don't know if this will come over here
but I'd definitely be excited to check
it out
it seems I think I like real animals
involved in the making of this film
yeah you see that bull riding at one
point you get you know a lot of horses
in there that anytime I see horses like
fall and other like train horses and
they're supposed
you said so but a lot of times when I
see that in movies I still feel bad for
them when like you see people like put a
spike through horses yeah oh there's
there's a whole lot of upsetting history
about like how we came to take care of
animals
this really does look like the lifestyle
of being a warrior in those times and
that's what I'm mostly intrigued by is
not not because oh cool spectacle and
cool violence it feels like I'm gonna
see what it's like to be a warrior back
then well here's the battle here's how
hard the battle is and here's what the
battle it's not just like battle on land
they have battles in the water they have
battles in the snow that had all kinds
of locations in this trailer that really
really drew me in so yeah thank you guys
for recommending that all you Russians
out there Russian Russian I must break
you
I think Sylvester Stallone captured the
country of Russia best in rocky for when
everyone quickly turned on their own and
started rooting for the Italian style
people feel about to Maura Beckman boots
up because like he came over here cuz
like the Night Watch caught on and stuff
like that and now he's making all his
moves in America wouldn't you do better
yeah you're becoming American stick to
your really about how they reacted the
last trailer yeah I hopefully they
notify us when there's like actual
screenings of this film come in the
permit class after premiere Russia I
would love to go I feel like my American
personality would fit in very well with
your community you're new to the channel
subscribe to the real rejects BAM tae-bo
Jesus Christ is blessed John with a
Twitter and Instagram handle called
reasons to Jerry he did he gave this to
me personally and Moses came back from
the dead he did and gave him
facebook.com slash the real
and facebooked on big tasks slash
reasons to Jerry we grew up Catholic so
we can say stuff like that oh it's
shout-out to uh a Russian XXX kitty-chan
XX she was one of the subscribers that
asked to for us to watch this trailer I
I wanted to say thank you for requesting
that she has the awesome hot blonde
Russian looks and that's why I said
we'll shout her out because you fit the
category of what Americans tend to like
from hot Russians oh boy
yeah yeah let's just type of culture
there we're not doing that we're not
complimenting I know I guess maybe not
then her Lane you know though you don't
want to put xxx and your uh your
thumbnail yeah you'll get diesels